reasontv presents citizens against  government waste quarter of the month  Kentucky representative Hal Rogers hello  and welcome to my new website here we've  spotted the rare 15 term congressman in  his natural habitat easily identified by  its mating call pork this invasive  species has become quite adept at the  art of spending taxpayer money according  to researchers in the field this  particular male is attempting to grant 5  million dollars a year to overseas  organizations that protect lions and  cheetahs why such odd behavior political  points the courage special interest  favors like the cheetah this species  works in small family groups called  coalition's and the congressman's  daughter is a grants administrator for  the Namibia based cheetah Conservation  Fund the American people deserve better  from their elected leaders you ain't  lyin cheatin more information on quarter  of the month and other government waste  issues visit CA GW org